so i understand too with kickstarter
that you
did your own research and that you
donated to certain campaigns to kind of
see how it worked is that right right um
about two years ago i started donating
to um campaigns i think i did like 12
initially and um i would say nine or ten
were successful
and i would get the updates and you know
i wouldn't read them all i was kind of
filtering like okay how is this gonna
work and
um i kind of got fascinated you know
because they were so neat i was just
thinking man what a neat idea to
really put yourself out there and to
play the game
the risk of failure
you know of uh
of just seeing if you can do it and um
it fascinated me so i started getting
involved and doing it then i didn't do
it for about a year i didn't contribute
for about a year because i was i was
doing another movie
and um
then after that wrapped and i was just
kind of back on kickstarter and i a
friend of mine had a kickstarter
campaign and you know you know you get
them occasionally
and uh i donated to his or contributed i
don't like that word donate it's con
contribute
um and it wasn't successful but i just
thought this is such a neat idea and i
think my fertility project
would be good for kickstarter
what was it about those various
campaigns that made you
contribute
aside from the one that was your friends
i mean what would you see
was it was it the video was it seeing
the director
or the the screenwriter in the video
what were some of the things um for me
it was credibility um i think that
this is where crowdfunding excels and i
think this is where crowdfunding and i'm
speaking as a novice complete novice of
crowdfunding
why it excels and why it doesn't excel
i've contributed to campaigns where i
saw the person
doing the video involved in the campaign
they had they had done the work to and
they had the credibility that warranted
my money
you know why should i give this person
20 or 30 or 50 or 100 bucks why should
you know have they done the work have
they put in the time the hours for my
money for my 20
and the answer was yes and i you can you
get a sense through the video through
their copy
to think okay they have what it takes to
pull this off i'm not even worried about
if i'm gonna get my reward or whatever
that is i believe in this person
and that's what made her break it then
you see videos to where
they're more like
nobody will give me a shot you know
i'm 20 years old help me which is that
those are fine those are all fine but
there's a there's a way to do those you
know you don't ask for as much money or
you present it in a certain way
but i invest in a lot of film projects
because that's where my mind went like
okay
how is this working
and i took a lot of notes and that's how
i crafted my campaign
you